alger le président mitterrand effectué
une visite de travail de quelques heures
au programme des entretiens le tchad le
sort des otages français le règlement du
problème posé par les enfants séparés de
leur mère française
alger pour antenne de reportage de
michel mercurol yves barbe la continuité
du dialogue entre deux pays amis
l'avancement des dossiers bilatéraux
mais aussi la qualité des relations
personnelles entre les président chadli
à mitterrand explique la fréquence de
leurs rencontres depuis déjà cinq ans
c'est dans la résidence privée du
président algérien que se sont déroulées
une bonne partie des entretiens
près de cinq heures ensemble qui ont
permis aux deux hommes à vaste tour
d'horizon plus efficace selon françois
mitterrand qu'une longue visite de 48
heures
le dossier des enfants des couples
franco algérien séparer pourra être
réglé à bref délai a dit françois
mitterrand les deux présidents ayant
particulièrement à coeur la solution de
ce douloureux problème
les deux hommes ont parlé des otages
français au liban
mais le chef de l'état qui a salué
l'aide algérienne ne souhaite pas
évoquer publiquement le dossier jusqu'au
dénouement de la situation
autre sujet le tchad où les pays qui
n'ont pas tout à fait la même approche
se retrouve maintenant en phase pour
conseiller une solution politique
si comme je l'espère le chevronné huawei
se trouve en mesure ainsi que monsieur
le président hissène habré d'organiser
en commun et au gré de leurs propres
décisions
avec elle je n'ai pas intervenir
une solennelle en même temps qu'ils
évidente réconciliation entre ceux qui
ce sont si longtemps combattu ce serait
pour le tchad
un événement d'une incalculable
importance peu m'importe les
protestations du colonel kadhafi a
ajouté encore françois mitterrand la
france est au service du droit
international elle défend avant tout
l'intangibilité des frontières